[Applaudissements]
pour larguer les amarres j'ai décidé de
vous emmener et de parler d'innovation
alors l'innovation c'est souvent tout
simplement la synthèse de milieux de se
faire qui ne se rencontrent jamais on
travaille plutôt sur des solutions qui
nous permettent de croiser le chaud et
le froid
le mobile elie mobile et d'avoir la
capacité d'arpenter des chemins qu'on
n'irait pas de premier abord arpenter je
vais vous donner un exemple je vais
prendre un objet qu'on va essayer de
transposer dans le domaine de
l'innovation
c'est un objet qui n'a absolument rien à
voir l'innovation va prendre par exemple
une huître une 8 à part le caractère
aphrodisiaque que lui connaissent les
asiatiques
on est plutôt sur le qi d'une huître
s'ils ont quelque chose de flasques de
très sales et de coupant les fêtes de
fin d'année montrent souvent que c'est
un peu dangereux même une huître
donc c'est très loin du monde de
l'imagination du monde de l'invention et
pourtant c'est là que tout commence
parce que quand on décide de projeter un
objet singulier dans le monde de
l'innovation
on arrive à générer dans l'invention ce
que je vous propose c'est d'arpenter le
chemin que nous avons arpenté que j'ai
arpenté mais d'abord pour vous dire
comme on y est arrivé j'ai vous dire
d'où on est parti je viens d'écouter des
coupés d'une famille aimante et des
côtes découpées d'une bretagne
armoricaine de la bretagne nord d'une
mer très amoureuse et d'un père
affectueux mais tu es e
j'étais plutôt à un élève moyen voire
ont pas très bon puisque à la fin du
collège
l'équipe pédagogique s'est cru très
intelligente en dix ans mes parents
vous savez emmanuel il n'est pas fait
pour faire des études supérieures faudra
mieux le mettre dans un lycée
technologique professionnel voire
agricole donc en seconde je me suis
retrouvé dans un lycée agricole
ma mère a pleuré mon père n'avait ni
armements maritimes pour que je devienne
capitaine de pêche ni exploitation
agricole pour que je devienne dans le
pays du chou fleur et et de l'artichaut
un agriculteur un gérant d'entreprise
ça a été la première claque
je me suis retrouvé avec des gens qui
pensaient pas comme moi qui vivent elles
mêmes sur le même territoire qui qui
arpentait les mêmes sentiers les mêmes
routes qui fréquentaient les mêmes lieux
mais qui ne pensaient pas comme moi je
me suis pris au jeu du relevé des défis
les gens m'ont dit mais t'inquiète pas
tu vas faire ton chemin bien évidemment
la famille derrière indiquant les
manuels passe ton bac d'abord le bac ce
sésame sans le bac on peut rien faire
alors j'ai commencé à relier mon premier
défi j'ai eu mon bac avec 10 03 mais je
les ai eus et puis je me suis pris
finalement au jeu de la proximité au jeu
de ce territoire des gens qui ne
pensaient pas comme moi et j'ai
poursuivi mes études
alors je fais de la génération tanguy et
j'ai tellement poursuivre mes études que
finalement j'ai terminé avec 10 ans
d'études après le bac un docteur en
biologie marine mention très honorable
fixation du jury etc et puis on disait
ben maintenant que tu as fait des études
trithois du boulot alors c'était les
années 90 la mort de nos héros du
rock'n'roll un chômage à 10% le sida la
chute du mur de berlin enfin vraiment
tout pour pouvoir s'éclater et
construire une vie heureuse et
épanouissante
donc ben j'ai trouvé un boulot ma mère
était super contente je travaillais dans
une administration française
et puis je discutais avec moins de plus
un parce que ben dans notre vie de
français d'européens pour nous ça compte
pour cent des gens sur la planète
travail 90 % sont salariés c'est ce
qu'on imagine donc j'avais rien tu sens
qu'il disait t'inquiète pas il venu à
lille avait à peine 10 ans puisque moi
disait manuel tu sais si tu fais comme
moi dans dix ans tu seras ma place le
problème c'est qu'il était mort au
sterne tiède donc je me voyais tout de
suite dans un bocal de formol au
sous-sol du laboratoire les ailes
brisées en dix ans pendant que je suis
là au moins quelqu'un pour am étudié
peut-être un jour j'aurai un espoir donc
j'avais pas forcément de plan b j'ai
fait la check list
et puis j'ai donné ma démission
seulement ben quand on fait ça on fait
un peu le point donc j'avais les
avionneurs low cost un passeport je
parler trois langues
j'avais un peu d'audace et d'ambition et
puis quand on a comme moi créer de la
connaissance est fait de la recherche on
a envie que ça crépite on a envie que ça
pétille et finalement il me manquait
tout ça donc j'ai fait le point et
de moi j'avais trois à tous mes envies
mes passions mes amours alors mes envies
d'abord c'était certainement pas d'être
dans un avenir aux tiède et morose une
une espèce de monotonie crasseuse dans
laquelle on a du mal à s'extraire
et puis j'ai commencé à discuter avec un
certain nombre de mes confrères et
notamment julien qui m'a dit un jour un
ami très proche c'est génial je vais
t'aider à trouver du boulot t'inquiète
pas c'est une mauvaise passe
tu vas réussir à se structurer viens me
rencontrer je vais les rencontrer et
julien me dit battue c'est le problème
c'est que ben moi je viens de contracter
un emprunt sur la maison j'ai deux
enfants et si je te recrute bas dont six
mois j'ai plus de boulot et toi tu as ma
place par contre si tu veux faire un
devis si tu me fais une facture mais
dans ce cas là je viens dire travailler
alors dans mon nom de deuxième claque
pour ça faut être une entreprise ou à
voir anne plus simple moins un des
bureaux une machine à café enfin tout ça
tout ce que j'essaye de quitter parce
que ça ne me correspond pas et puis non
mais t'inquiète pas je vais donner un
petit coup de pouce s'il ya un truc qui
s'appelle le portage salarial dû
recruter ou plus ou moins et puis on ne
te paye que quand tu ramènes du chiffre
d'affaires quarante huit heures après
j'arrivais avec un devis une facture je
vous disais j'avais fait le point
j'avais mes envies mes passions mes
amours alors mes passions on a tous dans
nos vies des gens qui ont un job
alimentaire et qui à 17h s'empresse de
débaucher en paye de leurs clés de
voiture et partent pour réparer la
mécanique d'un vieux 4 4 anglais ou ou
vont dans l'ambiance chlorophyllienne
d'un potager faire pousser des plantes
au fond du jardin etc ou travaillent à
la fabrication d'une goélette dans la
lumière tamisée d'un d'un grenier ça
veut donc dire qu'on gâche son talent
qu'on passe son temps à faire ce qu'on
n'a pas envie et qu'on a quelques fois
des échappatoires pour le faire or moi
même passion c'était envie de conquérir
des envies de conquête des envies de
voyages et ses envies de rencontre des
envies toujours de rencontrer des gens
qui ne pensent pas comme moi parce que
je pense que c'est comme ça qu'on
s'enrichit sinon les méninges se grippe
puis je vous disais que j'avais mes
envies mes passions puis mes amours les
amours c'est bien évidemment charnelle
mais c'est aussi l'envié de rencontrer
l'autre dans la fraternité les changes
faire éclore l'altérité rencontre est
toujours des gens qui ne pensent pas
comme moi vous voyagez imaginer
et puis finalement j'en suis arrivé à la
fin ou en ayant commencé à faire un
devis je suis devenu un peu par la force
des choses quelqu'un qui crée une petite
structure
j'apprends en marchant jeu j'apprends à
marcher en marchant c'est un petit peu
le segway vous savez ces bicyclettes
avec deux roues parallèles
si on se penche pas en avant ça n'avance
pas c'est ce qu'on appelle un stabilité
dynamique et finalement je me suis très
épanouie dans cette capacité de me
mettre un petit peu en danger de pro lgv
et un certain nombre de défis en
revanche j'avais pris le temps de
définir le périmètre du terrain de jeu
dans lequel moi je voulais aller
c'est-à-dire qu'elles étaient déserts
que je voulais conquérir quels étaient
les challenges que je voulais relever
c'était à la fin des années 2000 ont
commencé à parler d'environnement de
développement durable de digital tout ça
c'était un peu un espèce de magma
informe très nébuleux et on essayait de
se projeter en fait j'ai commencé
l'entrepreneuriat d'abord par créer mon
propre emploi
j'étais donc l'homme orchestre qui fait
tout tout le temps qui courent un peu
dans tous les sens et puis au fur et à
mesure de la cristallisation de projets
après avoir créé mon propre emploi j'ai
commencé à avoir des clients commencer à
structurer ce projet et puis j'en suis
devenu a passé d'homme orchestre un chef
d'orchestre en apprenant à devenir chef
d'entreprise
j'avais eu beau avoir fait des longues
études universitaires dans les écoles et
les universités que j'ai fréquentés on
ne m'a jamais appris à devenir chef
d'entreprise
j'en ai appris des choses sur les fuit
l'homme les cordes et sur la création de
la terre sur l'univers sûr mais
certainement pas sur la manière de créer
une entreprise
ma génération la génération x on est né
je vous disais non des environnements
qui était pas forcément très favorable à
la fin des trente glorieuses
on a eu notre adolescence sur des choses
qui étaient pas forcément très très
enthousiasmante et on avait surtout
cette espèce de grand couvert qu'on
mettait sur notre avenir en disant
attention ne sait pas de quoi l'avenir
est fait il est incertain
prenons d'abord une ceinture des
bretelles et l on dit doucement
bon bah moi j'avais pas envie d'aller
doucement j'avais envie que ça crépite
j'avais envie de phosphorer g20 me2 que
ça fasse débat y est quoi que ce soit
quelque chose qui soit sexy entraînant
enthousiasmant
et donc pas en devenant chef
d'entreprise j'ai structuré autour de
moi une équipe qui m'a permis d'avancer
qui m'a permis de savoir comment je
pouvais accéléré alors bien évidemment
on a toujours des gens à côté de nous
qui nous disent et notamment au niveau
familial au niveau amical pratique
doucement emmanuel tu sais pas comment
ça va se passer à l'avenir
prends ton temps quand ça vient de la
famille on le prend bien quand ça vient
des autres ben moi j'ai toujours gardé
cette petite phrase de michel serres qui
disait j'ai toujours pardonné à ceux qui
mentent aux français mais j'ai la liste
je la tiens à votre disposition si vous
le souhaitez puisqu'en fait j'ai la
capacité aujourd'hui de me dire ils
m'ont aidé et finalement tous ces gens
qui m'ont démoralisé qui monde est
motivé à montrer que ce défi là j'étais
capable de le relever d'abord parce que
j'en avais envie parce que j'avais de
l'audace parce que j'avais peut-être ce
côté un peu de folie d'ailleurs on me
disait toujours mais toi emmanuel c'est
pas pareil pour moi ça n'a jamais été
pareil non je sais pas pourquoi mais
pour eux c'était différent
donc j'étais pas souri aux mêmes règles
hockey dont acte si je suis pas soumis
aux mêmes règles autant le faire et j'en
veux pour preuve qu'il ya quelques
années
ça fait 15 ans que je suis entrepreneur
maintenant un drh dans un grand groupe
vendéen dans le domaine du négoce de
matériaux je le remercie tous les jours
quand j'y pense je fais un test de
personnalité avec lui une qui tue c'est
emmanuel tué inapte à être salariés
sam à économiser 15 ans de
psychothérapie et ça m'a permis de
pouvoir expliquer pourquoi j'avais 7 en
train cette attirance pour quelque chose
qui était différent cette volonté
d'entreprendre et c'est pas anodin c'est
quand on discute avec les gens de la
génération digitale des gens qui
souhaitent développer des projets
d'entreprise si on fait référence à des
structures qui sont plutôt anti qu'on
parle des bûcherons du numérique on
parle des barbares du digital
on est vraiment sur quelque chose qui
est lors de la conquête alors les
donjons et dragons et tolkien sont
passés par là on est vraiment là dessus
nous moi en particulier je me suis
plutôt inspiré de la devise des lumières
sapere aude et ces locutions latines qui
dit tout simplement aux savoirs n'ai pas
peur de faire confiance à ton propre
entendement hausse conquérir aux
découvrir aux plantes et aux avancées
hove découvrir tout ça c'était vraiment
structuré c'était vraiment la base même
et en construisant l'entreprise en
construisant mais l'entreprise
aujourd'hui on accompagnons des gens
avec moi j'ai eu la capacité de créer
cette espèce de de licorne cette espèce
de bestioles qui n'existe pas cette
sirène en faisant à la fois la synthèse
de l'innovation et de l'huître et comme
on l'a fait et bien tout simplement
on a créé une huître connectés qui
permet de lutter contre le vol des
huîtres alors c'est un exemple c'est
certainement pas un modèle mais c'est
l'exemple de la capacité qu'on peut
avoir
lorsqu'on décide de ne pas subir cette
théorie de la reine rouge par ckoi la
théorie de la reine rouge
c'est dans le deuxième tome du pays ça y
est le deuxième tome pardon d'alice au
pays des merveilles qui salissent qui
s'appelle alice de l'autre côté du
miroir
lewis carroll fait rencontrer une reine
rouge et alice sur un territoire
la reine rouge elle court elle court et
à les suivre
pourquoi est-ce que vous pourrez tan
rouge s'arrête et on a le sentiment que
la reine rouge recul en fait c'est la
métaphore de la vie en mouvement
parce qu'une proie qui ne bouge pas elle
se fera après date est une espèce qui
n'évolue pas elle se fait supplanter
elle disparaît un entrepreneur qui
n'innove pas il se fait dépasser par ses
confrères ou par ses concurrents et
finalement cette instabilité dynamique
cette volonté d'imaginer de créer
d'inventer de synthétiser des éléments
on ne peut le faire que quand on fait
tomber un certain nombre de barrières ou
alors qu'on définit nous nous mêmes
notre terrain de jeu
c'est ce que j'ai fait et quand on
définit ce pays ce territoire avec des
frontières qui sont plus ou moins
poreuse je vous invite d'ailleurs à
prendre un visa pour venir dans ce
territoire
c'est tout simplement qu'on arrive à
faire la synthèse de tout ça à être en
équilibre
peut-être en instabilité dynamique
parfois c'est pas toujours évident
l'entrepreneuriat mais ça nous remplit
au quotidien de joie et surtout
lorsqu'on a fait cette synthèse bonheur
égal performance je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]